taking Dilli on our first hunt is a
great way to balance this life the wild
and domestic guide pole
you hit it all right your turn
I feel pretty excited about my first
hunt I'm a little bit nervous about
taking a life and a challenge of hitting
a target and I think it will take my
rewilding journey to another level quail
are gonna run or they're gonna come up
from one spot and flush so same with
like pheasant
so your aiming point is like here maybe
it's just feeling it and then it travels
into that that place release boom so
that it comes together all right going
bird hunting with bows is gonna be a
challenge but getting meat is easily the
toughest thing about this life I think
it's a great opportunity for her to
learn that you ready I'm nervous you got
it Joe the wind took it huh I hesitated
just feel it you know yeah hunts away
for Delia to experience a little bit of
my side of rewilding
the hunt will really tug at our edges
and pull us into new places as a couple
pull yeah that feel good yeah felt
really good I think we can do it on some
birds okay Josh okay we'll try I'm
excited
there too